what do we do do you think to make
people smarter again I keep saying that
being smart is now counterculture
culture is dumb right now and when I
meet smart people I'm like thank God
culture is gleefully dumb that's the
problem I don't know that I don't know
that as a culture we're probably smarter
than we've ever been right right there's
this attitude that book-learnin is
somehow anti-american knowledge is
suspect science is political it's it's
very much an up is down down is up kind
of world but I still think that's a
that's a minority of the of the country
that really believes that yeah I firmly
believe it's a minority but it's the
minority that we keep hearing from I
mean that's what I kept saying in the
political side it's like we hear from
the crazies on the left then we hear
from the crazies on the right and I
would argue that most people I think
really 80% of us actually want pretty
decent things and pretty similar things
I think if you're oh yeah if you're just
a regular conservative you don't want a
world that's very different from what
the average liberal really want no no I
might have a couple of policies so how
do we how do we get those voices to be
heard well for one thing I think it's
important to to for the larger national
dialogue to state what you just stated
which is true and I would say it's even
larger than 80 percent we all
essentially want the same things we want
safe communities we want opportunities
for our kids we want the ability to make
a little money and feel like if we to
use the try this political expression
work hard and play by the rules we'll
get ahead that's basically all people
want right on both sides so if
conservatives can agree with that
statement and liberals can agree with
that statement you go fine we know where
we're going it's really just a question
of tactics on how we get there that's
where we disagree but as long as we keep
in mind that the goal is the same I
think we can work together yeah but we
become so and this is largely a result
of
and the entertainment aspect of
journalism we become so polarized
because that's what drives eyeballs to
television screens is people yelling at
each other as opposed to people having
comedy and being like oh yeah we agree
we basically agree right I mean another
yeah and that's it right yeah right but
what irony is people want that I know
they want it cuz they're messaging me
every day saying that what I'm doing
here is what they want to see the guy
that you're important we got God's work
we got it Dave
I think that listen if a hundred other
people were doing this I would gladly
find something else to read I really
would and that would show a good sign
that some smarter things have had
occurred here yeah that I I I wrote a
book a few years ago with my friend
Meghan McCain I wanted to ask you about
that yeah and that was essentially the
central thesis of the book which is we
don't kind of want the same things we
differ on on the margins may be a bit
about guns for example but even then we
don't because conservatives and liberals
both want gun deaths to fall right it's
just a question of how we get there
there's a certain disingenuous nasai
think on the part of the write about how
we get there mm-hmm and in fact entirely
disingenuous but just from a from a
purely philosophical point of view both
sides would like to reduce gun deaths
yeah so then it's just how do we get
there so when you wrote that book and
that's actually when I had you on my
Sirius XM show many lifetimes ago when
you wrote that I think I had Megan on
maybe the next week on something what
made you think like oh I should talk to
her because she's obviously she's in it
her her dad's a pretty powerful guy who
ran for president and you know but she's
on the right and I do you can do you
consider yourself on the left you just
yet so what made you think that like
this is for the parentheses you got a
couple more parentheses all right yeah
yeah what made you think like let me
talk to her and let's do that well that
was ahead of it yeah that was that was
the reason it was she's somebody who I
should have very little in common with
let's go on the road together and write
a book yeah and see if we can sort of
bring these issues to light a little bit
and we did it was fun and we wrote
good book and nobody bought it yes
nobody wants to hear could look more
similar and dissimilar yeah that's such
a dangerous that's the thing I want to
unpack with this more than anything else
is like we've got to get past it and
it's it's a it's a you know I turn on
CNN and it's like people think they're
watching news and they're not watching
news they are literally watching Wolf
Blitzer debate between a Trump spokesman
and a Hillary spokesman and people think
that that's news meanwhile Briggs it
happens and we don't even we literally I
watched CNN almost a full day just
trying to see like what are they gonna
show us it was on in the background I
didn't have the audio on the whole time
but like there was nothing they were you
know like at 1:30 second thing every
four hours right so it's like our media
is just making us dumb - yes I know I
think there's a certain percentage of
the population that will look at the
coverage of brexit and be curious enough
to want to understand more what that
means and there's a much larger
percentage of the population that
understands the headline of what brexit
is and doesn't need to pursue that any
further mm-hmm and then there's a
certain amount of the population who
doesn't give a [ __ ] I mean hasn't that
always been the way yeah always been the
case that that you know that I don't I
don't know I yeah if anything I feel
like we're more engaged as a nation than
we've ever been almost because we can't
help but be and I think that that's good
and bad I think what's going on in the
country right now there's there's
absolutely a Pollyanna ish way of
looking at it and saying this is
actually quite good what's happening
right that there is I mean aside from
people just being gunned down in the
streets which is it great so that you're
saying the issues that are being earth
DUP are good the question issues that
are being dredged up yeah are necessary
issues and they're being brought to the
fore by two imperfect messengers and
that's fine yeah that's fine
so as we're taping this right now black
lives matter is in like the throes of
there's a lot of stuff going on I mean
between the shootings of the black
people that has obviously been going on
for quite some time
but these last few in particular and now
the right are the protests against it
and then the cop shootings and
everything else where do you kind of
fall on all of this stuff because I find
it very hard and even even as I'm
pressing this I know that no matter what
we say right now a certain amount of
people are gonna hate it
no you know you mean even if they agree
with us a ninety-nine percent if we say
one word the wrong way people will start
freaking but I I so I haven't talked
about it that much because I find it's
very hard to decipher what's actually
happening by watching little clips of
things well there's a few things we know
that are happening no let's start with
the black lives matter beside of it and
incidentally I don't think these are two
opposing sides but just yeah separating
them out we know that black people are
being killed by police we know that
we've known it for years we've known it
for generations we've known it for
centuries black people get killed what
changed is obviously the ability to
livestream those deaths as they're
occurring it has changed the dialogue
it's very hard for white people to now
say or not to live in any kind of denial
about that now when you see the evidence
presented in front of you and there's a
lot of white people trying very hard to
maintain that denial yeah very hard yeah
but I think most of us look at that and
go oh yeah yeah we what you were saying
for the last 300 years I guess that's
right yeah the blatant denial people are
the ones that drive me nuts because you
could say that we can get to the other
part of this too you can say there's
some legitimate issues there but it's
the people that no matter what happens
no matter what evidence they're shown
right they immediately go to that well
that goes to character assassination
immediately yeah you know right right
right
somebody had you know weed in the car or
whatever will they deserve to get shot
no no they didn't right so there's that
side of it and then the other side is
that violence gets redirected towards
police and I haven't heard anybody
defend that
in any way shape or form other than a
couple crazy people on Twitter just
being idiots the two are the two ideas
are not opposed
we shouldn't be killing people like
that's let's just art with that central
premise
people are dying unnecessarily yeah and
they're I believe that there is a
incredibly entrenched and there's no
polite word for it racist culture in
police culture I've seen enough evidence
and read enough accounts and spent
enough time looking at looking at at it
and into it to suggest that that is a
problem
mm-hmm a real problem a genuine problem
for probably a plethora of historical
and cultural reasons so something's
broken with policing and I think always
has been but now we're just seeing it
that needs to change the idea that the
police force we've come to think of more
and more as a militarized force as an
extension of the military that has to
change it's weird it's weird that sorry
to cut you off but it's weird that
people don't see that that piece of it
where when we have these tanks out there
are not tanks but these armored vehicles
on our streets it happened that's
essentially yeah and that doesn't feel
like if you were just looking at it
removing the specifics
we've armored tanks on our streets
forget why they're there but that in and
of itself this is a more like a problem
like you shouldn't you should have to
call in the National Guard if you need a
tank pick up the phone call Gomer Pyle
yeah haven't bring the tank there's no
reason the police forces need them but
what it does is it inculcates and us
versus them mentality both from the
police's point of view and from the
community's point of view and the idea
of community policing is
the idea to protect and serve is lost
because it's become a the these police
precincts I think in many communities
have come to feel like occupying forces
as opposed to extensions of the
community it's a real problem the fact
that the fact that police routinely
recruit from the military I think is a
problem there's no there's no real
linkage between those two organizations
the police are paramilitary to a certain
extent but the local police force in my
mind should be essentially liaisons from
the law law enforcement to the community
and it should be a partnership it should
be a two-way street right so an Army is
dealing with enemy combatants but anyway
that police obviously should write their
can by definition an army is dealing
with with an opposing force yeah and
when you recruit from the military to
fill out your police ranks I have a hard
time believing that they're not going to
bring that mentality to policing and it
infects the entire culture and it's been
that way now for I think decades so what
do you make of because one of the things
that I've struggled with this is when I
see the protests and they're in the
middle of the street where they're not
supposed to be on highways and things
and you know when they've been burning
cars or whatever it is or looting sorts
of things look those things are not
legal you're allowed to protest but you
can't shut down highways and all that's
up and usually the cop usually not
always of course but usually you see the
cops basically trying to keep law and
order so it's sort of a self-fulfilling
prophecy here right well because you
could you create something you do
something illegal even if the intentions
are good let's say your motives are good
but you shut down a highway which you
can't do now the cops have to do
something and now you've created this
stalemate here and now of course
everyone's got cameras and everybody's
face and they're just waiting for the
pin drops right to set the whole thing
off so how do we how do we unfurl some
of that well there's you've given two
different examples that I think are not
quite the same too
there's a big difference between sitting
down in the middle of a highway and
burning a car and looting a store sure
but both are illegal
both are illegal yeah one is causing
property damage and destruction and is
is essentially a violent act versus the
nonviolent protest of sitting down in
the middle of a highway no but you could
be stopping ambulances that need to get
in all kinds of other stuff but you
could also do those sit downs in a park
you can't you know but you don't get the
fanfare you right and and protest is
about spectacle that is that is its
point so I may be annoyed at the people
sitting in the middle of the highway
but I don't have the same reaction to
that as I do to people being destructive
sure in their community and I think I I
think sitting down in the highway is a
perfectly viable nonviolent
demonstration where I think black lives
matter is falling short and I I was
reading this commenter commentator on
Twitter Oliver Willis who was talking
about this all night mm-hmm
without a directed legislative agenda
mm-hmm it's so much smoke but there's no
it can't catch fire there's no substance
there and I think that's true I think I
think at this point the black lives
matter umbrella because it's not really
it's not an organization right it's it's
whoever wants black lives matter can
claim it
whoever can you can claim yourself to be
a member of black lives matter and you
are but it needs it needs more directed
leadership it needs to have some stated
legislative and policy goals otherwise
all you're doing is you're raising
awareness for something that people
already know exists yeah this is the
inherent problem with that though that
they feel the system has failed them
either true either true or not so
they're there their goal is to make
waves not necessarily like they're
trying to change the system in a way
that the system doesn't want to change
like that's where this thing's at
loggerheads right yeah but do you like
if a guy came out and said I have this
legislation that's going to do this and
this and this it's almost like well the
protesters wouldn't wouldn't be down
with that that's possible because again
it's the blank slate theory it's easy to
say I project all my hopes on to X X
candidate X political movement it's much
harder to go to then take the next step
to y&z and saying well here are some
legislative differences we can make and
it's not going to be perfect because it
never is but we can move we can move
ourselves forward yeah in fits and
starts
yeah that's what we need wouldn't it be
fun to talk about some of this stuff
with some level of comedy involved but I
get you I get you like it's I I warned
you in an email I prepared for me not to
be funny I'm not gonna be funny and I
said I wanted one applause break we
don't even have a studio audience but I
was hoping for one one minor applause
break there I don't know how to talk
about this stuff is it funny right I
mean I just find it interesting I mean
I'm just I'm just some dude who reads
the newspaper and it's just interested
in it and doesn't doesn't pretend to
know how to make it funny yeah are there
any comics right now that you really
think you're hitting this out of the
park just sort of the general caller
political stuff yeah you know the the
people who came from The Daily Show I
think are still doing the best work in
that arena yeah we still we need John
back right I had some issues with him
but I think we need him back he was the
best yeah I think he's coming back right
he's got some HBO
he's gonna do like little snippets on
HBO or something but I mean sort of that
nightly long-form it would be great it
really would be yeah so let's let's
shift to movies and comedy and TV and
but but we could probably circle it back
to some horrific societal stuff and end
of civilization stuff but in case
society ends I want you to at least be
able to share your thoughts on some of
the movies you've made and some of the
others better talk about wonky [ __ ] we
could you know what five minutes of it
all right I was gonna go for 12 to 15
we'll do five minutes and then we'll
finish back with all this stuff
so first off I was telling you right
before we sat down that you were in wet
hot American summer which I hadn't seen
until about a year ago even though I
went to one of those camps I went to
camp Shanna wound up in Pennsylvania and
I thought it was one of the most
absolutely hilarious moves ever seen I
watched the series on Netflix which now
you just told me you're writing for
season two right which is pretty great
but you didn't write for sure I did not
write for season one I did not write the
movie yeah is that hard for you in a
movie like that where there's it's so
many of your friends obviously writing
and you didn't get to write but you have
to just act it is that harder than if
you're writing for it and acting and uh
no I mean I've been friends with all of
those guys
essentially my entire adult life so it's
as if I wrote it yeah you know we share
a sensibility so it's just it was just
fun yeah and and it's not like they were
so precious with the words that you
couldn't so they let you kind of do your
thing I would imagine you guys are
having a great time because it's great
it's really fun yeah and now now I'm I
mean I'm nervous writing for it because
I feel like I have something to live up
to where as a writer which I didn't have
just showing up on set so I'm I'm I'm
conscious of of not [ __ ] up something
that I think is really funny yeah all
right so we're gonna pack all the comedy
stuff in real quick so you're working on
like 87 other things
you're on Gaffigan you're doing
something that I just saw a billboard or
another period yeah yeah yeah so that's
I haven't seen it but it's like it's
like a take off Downton Abbey that's
true and Abbey it's as if well they they
pitched it to me as the Kardashians
meets Downton Abbey and that's
essentially what it is and it's really
funny yeah all right sorry I need we're
channels in on Comedy Central I actually
know that I should have I should have
known that I apologize just we were
brewing the whole interview it doesn't
matter to me I'm not here to plug [ __ ]
you're not plugging I'm you're not
plugging you said well let's talk about
the real stuff that's all I want to talk
about all right does let's let's circle
back to the real stuff so I mean I've
got other shows out too what's your
favorite thing that guide of all the
things you don't see this too I always
associate you with that I love the 80
stuff which probably does that cause you
to like roll your eyes kind of like it
was but you were like it was almost as
if they that whole genre of stuff which
you know they did a zillion shows after
that best
we got Vern Island 70s I love the 90s I
love the 20s or whatever else they and
now every channel has those shows - but
you were sort of the one that like got
it did you kind of really like you
figured out what that thing was that
that commentary thing was I think in a
way that some of the other people maybe
didn't get well when when it first
started it was much more sincere it was
much more like Soleil moon Frye going do
you remember wacky wall-crawler I miss
wagon wall crawlers right and that was
never my approach to it my approach was
just just make jokes yeah I feel totally
comfortable [ __ ] on your childhood
right now and that
yeah they eventually the tone of it
shifted more towards that then then the
can you remember wacky wall-crawler
Satomi yeah speaking of the eighties the
Sega Genesis do anything for you because
I help nothing no my time that was so
your 8-bit Nintendo or ColecoVision or
like a vision in television Atari 2600
Wow
so even 8-bit Nintendo we only have five
years apart the technology changes man
yeah moves very fast yeah I was I had
graduated from video games and by the
time the Sega Genesis came out
you